jetzt ein paar jahre zurück konkret ist
aber der nächste ich hab einfach wohl
hexen hexen hexen ist das nicht deswegen
ist alles ein bisschen neugier
servus es geht auch an alle zuschauer
von logo ein herzliches willkommen zur
neuen folge von minecraft legend das ist
glaub ich die zehnte quasi ein jubiläum
und wir gehen erst mal drauf auf den
stürmer mit dabei ist natürlich auch der
logo hallo und wir haben uns folgendes
überlegt heute ihr habt zu recht
angemerkt dass ich noch einen stack
sieht habe hier das drop direkt mal auch
das geht ja nicht machen oder so und
dann machen wir heute einfach so schön
das weizenfeld ist der logo wird jetzt
anfangen und ich mag das aber gerade
heftig für die ganze linke seite leute
mir sagen welche bugs nutze um keine
ahnung dinge zu finden so wir haben
jetzt ja anfangen business trip main
weil ich weiss stück mein logo macht was
anderes und einmal nun könnt ihr das
mister x und dom von andy hat in unserer
höhle gewesen wären ach wirklich
ach ja genau naja ok und leute
verwundert warum ich sinnlos in pause
das liegt ganz einfach daran dass mit
maxis also ich bin ihm gerade an max
rechner auf als irgendwas nicht zu 100
prozent stimmt liegt das daran
ich nehme einfach gerade auf dem rechner
von einem bruder auf ich bin nicht bei
mir zu hause habe nicht meine
einstellung
deswegen ist alles ein bisschen neugier
jedoch hier erstmal in die kiste aber
auch schon unser eisen dran liegt weist
bescheid weiß schon was es jetzt komm
ich komme ich komme ist einfach nur
einen finger weg von dir ist lässt es
etwas lassen diese diesem spiel kann die
es mehr anfassen
tut mir leid aber ja ich denke es war
ein polo gibt euch das hier komm ich
kann hier umschauen
guck mal ich hab gerade vor die anzeige
bugs und kann er andere hüllen sehen
hp waren das keine noten blöcke die
namensform mitgenommen haben sondern
waren das waren das plattenspieler zu
meinem plattenspieler man kann sein ja
schön leute pause die tastatur rockt uns
mal wieder aus dem leben hier kann
nichts machen aber wenn man schon mal
die das gefunden so früheren erfolge ist
es ein extrem gutes zeichen würde ich
sagen wir könnten uns so die geile
kürbiskuchen fahren machen ist tot wir
haben ja hähnchen geführten gefunden
haben wir hinten gefühl denn und leute
wo es vergessen wir haben natürlich auch
twitter fragen vorbereitet damit euch
diese wunderbare farben folge noch
spannender wird und zwar logo so ein
kleines tablet und da kann alle fragen
aufsehen mache ich gerade strip meine
oder manchmal einfach das war ich glaube
ihr mezzo die folgen wieder gehen weil
ich nehme mal zwei eisen ihr irgendwas
wir können und dann auch was wir noch
machen werden
irgendwann kurz an die oberfläche
begeben und da läuft über junge kommt
der denn her also ich kann noch blocken
habe kein herz verloren aber trotzdem
drop der kripo auf helfer wieder die
übel krass frage der hammer raus die
mary die hat übrigens sehr viele fragen
gestellt oft ja leute mit dem einrad um
halb drei auf das um diese uhrzeit noch
überhaupt jemand fragen stellt ist
einfach krass sich marie du bist aber
ich denke und wir bauen jetzt mal auf
meinen ja weil logo nimmt die sache
wirklich ernst mit logo muss man sagen
bei ihm ist alles logisch ungefährlich
wenn irgendwie wenn der morgen aus dass
zu hause gehen würde und er wird vom
piano erschlagen aus dem dritten stock
unterfeld oder sein fünftes bisschen
flach dann niedrig dann würde sagen ja
ich fahre jetzt zwar aber das war eine
wunderschöne habe ich eine anzeige buck
das ist einfach wie x-ray eine anzeige
wachs einfach wie x-ray ich sehe einfach
das da drüben so schön viel gold war und
wo aber ich versuche es mal nicht zu
nutzen leute bad bank nicht gerne alle
reporter.de einlädt support at google
mail senden
dort wartet gerne der liebe weiß darauf
dass alle leute hier aus legend report
werden und den link dazu findet ihr in
der beschreibung
das mache ich lieber nicht anschreiben
das wie wirklich leute nur mich
loszuwerden aber erzählen einfach mal
wie du auf der annahme das ist eine sehr
lange geschichte also begreifen ist ein
paar jahre zurück
konkret ist aber der ex ich hab einfach
wohl hexen hexen hexen ist das nicht
ließ das war's jetzt das was leute was
geht ab hier hab ich heftige rolex oder
hab ich heftige rolex was wollte ich
meine natürlich lol lol lol was kann ich
machen dass das dass die sache geht er
hasst du musst im multi core an videos
ich mache ihn auf default ja okay okay
bauleiter eu alex leider ausgeschaltet
so gewollte dass da unten haben ist das
gold oder reisen das ist doch bei meinem
namen ein bisschen weit zurück locker
ein paar jahre jetzt wieder auf dem
buckel
und zwar hat das was mit meiner schule
zu tun
da haben wir heil zu rechner sie sind
jetzt wirklich richtig richtig langsam
wenn man so betreuungsstunde hat man
kennt das so als normaler schüler darf
man das schulgelände noch nicht so
verlassen weil da keine busse fahren und
die haben ihre aufsichtspflicht unseren
scheiß und haben uns auf diesen
schlechten laptop sie quasi nicht
schlucken beim skifahren angemeldet und
die dinge die nicht schlucken also immer
schlechter kann man das sagen kann ich
kann nicht so flache witze raushauen
ich danke ich meine es jetzt wirklich
später nach deute ich hoffe ihr guckt
einfach auch späte nacht und können aber
über so etwas lachen das hoffe ich
wirklich ins laufen weiter im text
erzählt da waren schon recht genau und
da habe ich mich beim skifahren
angemeldet und braucht etwas simples das
habe ich erst dann lohnen so bin ich
eigentlich auf logo bekommt dort über
wasser gemeldet browsergame my free farm
hast du die angemeldet da habe ich über
die farben gestaltet ihr gegönnt
hier hab ich da was soll das eigentlich
ach ja das ist die folge sich
abgeschaltet natürlich hab ich vergessen
wie gesagt heute es ist noch nicht alles
fängt eingestellt weil ich werde man
abnehmen aber nach maß hin
es geht langsam das eisen aus also
brauchen wir also den 30iger till reuter
hatte habe ich noch nicht fertig wird
dann strikt ist die gal hier ist noch
ein eisen drin entspannt wie bist du auf
dein gekommen ich bin auf meinen
gekommen ich hab mein gott
gehört wir eröffnen weil auch einen blog
panel zu zweit wo wir dann immer nur wer
bin ich machen und so also das nennen
was ist das der fürbitte anblick war
hier wird einfach seine angespült wird
es an das kann gerade level formen seien
hier gegner dieser mail dann müsste ja
was ausdenken ihre symbol ich laufe ja
ich halte es für mich eigentlich nicht
sagen was anderes umschaltet
abgeschaltet ausgemacht heute sprach ex
ich habe einfach cool aber man die wir
aus dem eigenen keller bringt irgendwie
also ich habe jetzt keinen zweiten
channel aufmachen und ich glaube ich
noch nicht bei meiner größe
wer nicht um gespielt was mir
aufgefallen ist
über krass über krass ich habe heute
gespielt mal reingeschaut den er mal
reingeschaut und weißt du was den der
wirt ungespielt einholt und überholen
wenn ich mit dir die die mitarbeiter
noch 50.000 arbeitsabstand das ist immer
so dass der relativ nah ran kommt
der hatte früher 200.000 autos abstand
ja ja aber es war eine zeit weh
diskutieren gerade vom thema weg ich
will das jetzt nur klarstellen er den er
war schon vor den eine million war schon
richtig nah an in ungarn person aber den
mietern da immer 150.000 2000 akkus
kleiner aber ich glaube die wir mit dem
bald einholen und fällt sogar überholen
leute also ich sehe da rauskommen aber
gute kommen wir zu meinem namen drauf
gekommen bin
wir habe max hat sich einfach mal
irgendwo überlegt so also markiert der
name kann tatsächlich von max hat sich
einfach über das war ein cooler name und
hat meine initialen einfach so obst
andere gang
das ist damit der ballon wahrscheinlich
vom ist am ohr oder so ok und hat dann
einfach so eine alte ist meine initialen
irgendwie umgestellt und so amerikanisch
ausgesprochen
und man kann nun wie escada aber da
hatten wir doch nicht beteiligt das war
nur macht dann kam irgendwie erst heraus
als meine initialen
umgestellt irgendwie anders
ausgesprochen
visiert es ist zudem kam raus nächste
foto wie würdet ihr als mädchen heißen
ist eine gewisse fragebogen natürlich
china ist dass du gesagt aber ja ich hab
mal dass eine lustige geschichte ist
habe ich vor noch screen erzählt ich
habe man minecraft eine gewisse logik
getroffen to hell wie zu hell wie dir
ganz angelegt angelegenheit die ich habe
eine zweistellige zahl und sie hatte
einfach eine dreistellige zahl ohne
scheiß sie war einfach perfekt
dann hat sie den server verlassen hatte
die auf die gleiche quersumme zufällig
weiter 13 oder ich stoße die ganze zeit
aufgänge von anymore glaube ich meine
fresse
es muss ja nicht sein nur weil das leute
in die kommentare schreiben dass es der
eingänge sind ja okay ist aber sind
gamer also es sind gänge keine auge
davongekommen aber sind gänge
ja natürlich sobald ein fenster lehnen
ja aber wenn die da war aber leute nein
ich hatte gehörte garten guten einfall
dings der scanner wolf der fleißige
zuschauer und schreiber hat letztens war
gemeint ich sollte doch mal eine folge
mit shader spiel bleibt wenn jetzt unter
der erde sind klar machen
guckt man ja was wir hatten schäden
haben müssten die nicht irgendwo landen
müssen müsste hier nicht im menü
angezeigt werden hass nein nein wenn du
wenn du das nicht installiert das dann
geht das nicht hast du die separat
installiert und muss ich nur alle die
scheider muss alle installieren für
dieses technik installieren
das ist sehr kompliziert das ist ja
reduziert weil ich irgendwie
schneiderhan waren aber geht das war
nicht okay habe ein bisschen reisen
auch nicht schlecht nehmer mit wir
werden die basis jahr noch ein ganzes
stück hier nutzen oder wer jetzt einfach
so lange gehen bis wir genug die haben
für bisschen schüsse für eine entspannte
und dann können wir uns ein bisschen
weil dann kann ich die basis hier auch
einmal richtig macht unseren du musst
jetzt muss jetzt keine zierleisten ein
bauer aus mahagoni aber du kannst ein
bisschen kann schon sagen wo kommt die
lage wissen aus der wand wir sind
einfach um die uhrzeit so richtig feroli
ist aber noch mehr gänge überall
wie geht s feld voran erzählen ja ich
muss ich bei bhp billiton eine erdgas
gestoßen und für die graz ein bisschen
aus jetzt mit kumpels turnier und hier
kommt jetzt das feld alles rein
wir bräuchten aber mal eine vierer
wasserquelle damit nun endlich wasser
haben das wäre praktisch des todes die
braut für reicht nicht aus doch klar
also wenn du hast ja nun endlich
wasserquelle damit mit vier mit mit 2 x
2 oder wie ja nämlich mit 2 x 2 mit 42 x
22 x 2 endlich ja
zwei ecken hast du dann zweimal endlich
endlich machen oder willig alter step
toward creating gang rein was denkt er
sich dass sie jungfräulich geklopft ich
drehe mich auf den fußball
die miss geworden und ich gern mal
wissen nicht ob alles aus na gut ich
würde wie würde ich als mädchen heißen
keine ahnung
schreibt man die kommentare wie er mich
als mädchen dann würde aber irgendwas
schön dass nicht sie nicht so saskia
oder so irgendwas schönes kannst du mir
mal eine neue reise nix machen oder weiß
was ich mache mir direkt 2
übertreibt nicht du sollst doch kein
holz reinsetzen
du bist doch kein architekt
ich habe mir noch einen goldring habe
ich auch noch sechs strings die sag mir
fällt auch in meine kiste packen wir
auch unbedingt diese unruhen aber eine
sache bekommen zufrieden ich haben apple
warum auch immer ich habe bei mir nicht
anders behandelt dann zum megafon
agentur an die wunderbare aufnahme
leicht
ob die überhaupt gespeichert wurde ja
hier 14 minuten
ich schaue dass ich noch dass man
irgendwie auch so gehen wir noch eine
minute macht kann er noch kurz mit der
leute ihr wisst gar nicht beschädigt das
ist nachts um 3 auf zuletzt 4 43 ist die
beste zeit trainings noch schief wird
info für alle die noch so lange
geblieben sind eventuell fällt morgen
max nach köln und besuchte er den
kongress und den crafter und den kriegs-
oder rotterdam gewinnen kennt den osten
und besuchte logan das mosten alter ganz
ehrlich sagen die leute wir bleiben
friedlich hier unten beantworten die
tour de france für euch gucken sonst
wissen schaden und dann gehen wir mal
die oberfläche in zukunft werden sich
nämlich auch die welt ein bisschen mehr
verteilen aber wir werden auch vor allem
nicht mehr so spät aufnehmen dürfen
sondern nur noch in gewissen zeitfenster
und da sind dann alle auf den servern
gibt es klappe und ich sogar dass the
nation ist optimist und wir unser dem
wieder zurück das ist abgezogen haben
drei leute das eine positive bewertung
da und bis zum nächsten